[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
spring in chris collins we're sunday
night football
analyst pro football focused majority
owner the chris collinsworth podcast
he'll be with al michaels on the call
sunday night tom brady and drew brees
uh it's a big event weekend on nbc also
the breeders cup classic on
friday and saturday clemson notre dame
in prime time saturday night
nascar cup series championship on sunday
afternoon
how's morale chris what up brother you
started going through wisconsin and
michigan i thought i was listening to
the election again
now sir do you do what i do do you sit
up
and and like every election night i used
to love doing this even though it's
during the season and
you're a little worn out anyway and the
whole thing but i would love
sitting up and watching the whole
election night coverage and a little bit
of the history of it and everything and
now
it's like election month the election
week
you know i don't even know what you call
it anymore i did not
stay up to watch it uh because i think
that it's probably going to be a few
days
before this is even uh called so i
i just thought no matter what it said
tonight or last night
uh there's no finality to it i'd rather
just wait let it all
spill out and then sort of slice and
dice and consume it after that
yeah got to say hi to bobby knight there
i miss seeing bobby
he used to come to all the events around
town i got a chance to see him and talk
to him a lot and
one of my all-time favorites so that's
that's some collection you got going on
that desk right there oh yeah
yeah i got um yeah i just collect
everything what's the
greatest piece the best piece of sports
memorabilia you have
you know which one i i kind of like the
most is i've got
everybody's autograph on the 1980
olympic hockey team on a picture you
know the
the picture of them going crazy at the
end of the game and
i always wanted to put i need to get out
and do a thing where you know
the call of the game where i can just
push a button and walk by the picture
and push a button
do you believe in miracles
how does uh tom brady incorporate
antonio brown
or bruce aryans do this on such short
notice
i i think he's a perfect fit for this
team right now i mean
i'm assuming antonio brown is still
antonio brown
okay i'm just i'm just going to say this
i'm just going to talk football for a
minute
because the one thing in watching the
tape here of of tampa
is that they they really miss having
that inside threat you know how many
times have we seen tom brady
with james white or whatever just one on
one
you go up on the linebacker you make a
break to the left you make a break to
the right get him the ball
beautifully accurate thrown pass and
they really don't
have that right now i mean that's not
ronald jones's game it's not leonard
fournette's game coming out of the
backfield
um they're they're a good power running
team this is one of those
old school offenses in tampa and it's
starting to come together um
it looks like tom brady in new england
now i mean
they don't run a ton of zone stuff they
run more
power blocking downhill physical
and and it and every week that i watch
them it looks
a little bit better than it did the week
before of course the play action off of
that
but now they even have mike evans in the
slot with no chris godwin even mike
evans is starting to come down and
playing in the slot
gronk is looking better than he was
looking a few weeks ago
so all these pieces are coming together
i just think what they're still missing
is that middle of the field threat
against man-to-man coverage just that
quick
change of direction kind of guy and and
you know who's better at that than
antonio brown or at least he was better
at that
than anybody else i also was looking at
the offensive line and i did have
questions about that offensive line
but they've been together for the most
part this entire season and if you look
at all the injuries to all the other
offensive lines around the nfl i mean
it's kind of remarkable that
i think they've only missed a few plays
together
um and and brady it feels like
understands or they understand brady
just give me this amount of time and
we're fine like that that's almost like
the blocking scheme what have you seen
they're better than that they really are
because they're they're physical
running the ball remember the old play i
i bet you i've drawn up this play for
patriots
games a thousand times the guard pulls
out
they have a deep play action pass and
then you hit gronk over the middle right
i mean that's that's sort of their bread
and butter well they're getting back to
that now
and they're getting back to that now
because they can run the ball
uh effectively so you're starting to see
these guards pulling i'm starting to see
some old counter trays from the
washington redskins days
it's a very old school they jumbo a lot
they'll put in
joe hegg is the sixth offensive lineman
but when you start pounding the ball and
running the ball with tom brady as your
quarterback
now you get back to that play action the
guard pulls
linebacker jumps up to try and fill the
gap here comes gronkin behind here comes
evans uh and and we have yet to see this
offense
complete we have yet to see all the
receivers on the field it's been a
really tough year for gronk
he's not blocking like he used to block
because he's got that bad right shoulder
he's just getting creative
turning his shoulder trying to make
blocks and do different things
but i think as you as you project this
team forward
if they can get healthy again and if
this offensive line stays together i
think they could be pretty darn good but
you know more about tampa
or new orleans um
a little bit more about tampa at this
point
only because we were getting ready to do
tampa
in vegas um and then we got
coveted out of that one when trent brown
got sick that they
we didn't know if we were going to do
the game and so then they were telling
fred godelli it's like it's your guy's
call
you can stay on that game but if it gets
canceled we'll give you another game
but you might be calling carolina from
the booth in las vegas
i was like what was like a day's notice
you know
and i was like oh that doesn't seem very
smart so then
it got down to well where are you going
to move the truck right
so we're in vegas so yeah we'll take the
we'll take the game in new england that
was i think it was san francisco that
week
but we couldn't get the truck there so
then it ended up
the next closest place was arizona
seattle and arizona and ended up being a
fantastic game so once again the the
luck of the irish came through
he's chris collinsworth you'll be on the
call sunday night football and
of course uh majority owner pro football
focus the chris collinsworth podcast
would you trade for a veteran this time
of the year if you were
green bay let's say you could get stefan
gilmore
and it was going to cost you a
first-round draft pick
no i wouldn't take steph on because the
reason they're trading him i think is
that he got hurt
you know he had something with his knee
or whatever
the old buyer beware right this time of
year you have to know
why is that guy up on the trading block
and
and too
well and the one thing you know about
belichick is that he will
trade them a year or two early so if
you're right on the brink and you think
you're
one player away maybe i wouldn't mind
doing that deal with belichick because
there's a lot of gm's and coaches out
there
they don't have the 10-year plan anymore
right they're on the brink of losing
their jobs
and i always thought that was one of the
weaknesses of the design of having
gms and coaches make all the decisions
about the organization
is when these guys start getting on the
bubble or start struggling
well of course i'm going to trade
tomorrow's draft choices
for today because i got to keep my job
first and foremost
so you always have to watch that a
little bit as well as some of these
deals come down what about jj watt
does he have value in the open market
uh of course yeah of course
well how about a first round draft pick
for j.j watt
if you're like throw out you know
anybody who needs help
like green bay can't stop the run like
would green bay and you give a late
first round draft pick for j.j watt
that's a really interesting question i i
think the ordinary
thought would be no just because he's a
little older and has
the the history of injuries second round
pick
possibly if you thought you were really
really
right there on the brink of something um
you know i listen i i played until i was
30.
and it felt like i got to 29 and i was
feeling
good i'm still going out dancing and
having fun in the clubs and doing all
that
i got to 30 and i became an old man
everything fell apart on me
everything i don't know what it was now
these guys probably know how to train
and take care of their bodies better
than i did
wait wait you were dancing in the club
well yeah i had my
yeah my fiance was with me at that time
if you want to be that specific with it
yeah but yeah
that's how we used to get loose man when
after a game
i swear after a game this we did it all
the time
you know because you get the lactic acid
you get you know you go from man i feel
great leaving the stadium let's go out
we're going to go partying
and then you go sit on the couch and i
used to watch you know you guys do your
highlights and do all that kind of stuff
and and then you get up an hour later
and you can't move
right you're like ah you know you feel
like that so then what do you do you go
out and
you have a cocktail you start dancing a
little bit and everything gets loose
again
do you hold a grudge against anybody you
played against
hold a grudge against anybody i played
again the only
the only guy who really drove me crazy
but cheap shots
did anybody take a shot that you just
never let go of that
frank minifield called his shot on me
and said he was so i had a big game
against cleveland i had about 150 yards
the first game we played them
frank minifield said he was going to
knock me out of the second game in the
newspaper
right in the newspaper say he's going to
knock me out
i'm like oh okay i said
i'm from the first play i'm going down
and taking a 15-yard penalty i am
chopping this guy's legs i'm clipping
him i'm gonna roll up i'm gonna take his
ankle in my hands i'm gonna try and snap
it
i'm gonna do anything i can to kill this
guy
i come back and get the line of
scrimmage and boomer audibles to a
quick screen to me like a wide receiver
screen to me out there
i was like all right but i'm going to
get your ass next time you got one play
off here
so i come up and he throws this quick
screen and it's the last thing i
remember
it's the last thing i remember minifield
comes up and i don't know what he hits
me with
i i you know remember in wrestling he
has a foreign object i think
and i'm out i am out and i so i'm
sitting there and so they finally like
wake me up
and i get up and and i'm
i can remember running off the field and
i got to the bench
and i'm standing over and i'm on the
bench and all of a sudden
i kind of come to whatever i knew this
was the first play of the game
and i come to and i look up at the
scoreboard and it was like 13
20 whatever and i go oh good good good
good i didn't miss anything
second question
so i stand up and i fall down
my apparently i had fallen back over my
ankle and my knee so i'm completely gone
i don't know what quarter it is i can't
walk
and i still want to go get after frank
midfield's
ass because he said he was going to hurt
me which he did so yes i do hold a
grudge about that
what was his number 37 what was his
number
maybe 31 31 31 i think that might be
it thirty-one hanford uh good players
yeah yeah yeah but but you never did
was it a cheap shot when you saw it or
was it just
a great tackle by him it was a foreign
object
i'm totally convinced he's not that
tough a guy i've seen him a hundred
times since then that's
what i tell him you're not that tough a
guy what did you have in your hand
he picked up one of the batteries you
know whatever they were throwing at
something in there uh do you got a good
handle on the steelers
um yeah i watched a good bit of that i i
you know what impressed me most about
the steelers
is that they had that game against
tennessee and i don't know if you
watched that one or not but that was a
bloodbath i mean
they were trying to kill each other out
there right
so much so that we came back and on
their pff show they have been picking
the games and all
so i said i tell you what i am not
picking
either the steelers or tennessee
the week after this game teams simply
cannot put together
back-to-back physical games like
what that game was and i was right about
tennessee tennessee came back and they
got beat by cincinnati
pittsburgh goes into baltimore
and it's if anything bloodier than the
one that they had
in tennessee and just went toe to toe
for the entire four quarters i i i can't
tell you how impressed i am with the
pittsburgh steelers
putting two of those games back to back
together
to stay undefeated and they're not even
close yet on their offense i mean
i i still think offensively
they're going to get better and if they
do with the way they're playing defense
right now
they're going to be tough but also i
remember that bettors would tell me
whoever played seattle the week after
they played seattle
always bet against that team when they
faced the legion of boone
that they weren't like that yeah they
were going to get beat up
i i like that you know richard sherman's
on the podcast that i do
yeah i wasn't going to even do i wasn't
even going to do a podcast and they said
so he said
well i get you richard sherman as a
guest and i i is my way of getting out
of the podcast
i said you get me richard sherman every
week to do the podcast i'll do one
they got richard sherman so i'm doing a
podcast every week i don't know how
but he is truly one of the most
interesting guys to talk to
week in and week out he's not afraid he
talks about whatever he wants to talk
about
it's really been fun yeah i saw that you
were doing that
along with pro football focus and then
football night in america
you're busy my life sucks
no it's great i mean i really you know
what if you're if you're gonna
watch football all day the idea of
talking about football isn't that bad a
job right i mean it's actually
i'm taking a break right now from my
film study to come in here and talk so i
was thrilled to get a chance to take a
break and come see bobby knight
but are you okay with being criticized
i'm criticized all the time i know it's
still not
easy you know you can read chris you're
great and then there's one guy
saying whatever and that you know one
out of ten will stay with you
every every single week i say
something that somebody considers to be
the dumbest thing they ever heard in
their life
every week i mean do i go do i go
looking for it i don't generally my kids
send it to me right they cannot wait for
whatever i screw up
i i've got one i had one i can't even
say it because
it's like it's like so foul
right that i i can't even i would feel
uncomfortable
saying it but it's also hilarious
because it was totally
innocent on my part and by the time that
i got
home my kids had made a video of what i
said and put it on a loop
and it just like just ran all day
i'm like i'm like oh please make it stop
please i
and you have no idea i mean half the
time i leave the stadium
i have absolutely no idea what stupid
thing i've said this week
and then you go on like social media and
you and you look at it like
you know you cover your eyes and you
start flipping
because you don't know what it is you
don't know what it is that you did
this week but every week and something
good to visit with you
my best to holly and uh we'll be
watching sunday night
thank you man anytime give me a call
that's chris collins where's sunday
night football
got a podcast there with richard sherman
and uh
he got in early with pro football focus